ya hemos pensado en las curvas de
demanda para una competencia perfecta y
en los monopolios y en los tipos de
ganancias económicas que podrían
resultar en este vídeo vamos a
centrarnos en algo intermedio de lo que
hemos hablado en vídeos anteriores que
es la competencia monopolística como
puedes ver en los tres escenarios
tenemos una estructura de costos similar
tenemos nuestra curva de costo marginal
y nuestra curva de costo total promedio
que está en un punto mínimo justo donde
se intersecta con la curva de costo
marginal pero cuando se trata de la
curva de demanda es muy diferente si
estamos hablando de un monopolio o una
competencia perfecta para una
competencia perfecta esta es una de las
muchas empresas con un producto
homogéneo y sin barreras a la entrada
por lo tanto estas empresas sólo tienen
que ser precio aceptantes cada una de
estas empresas debe aceptar el precio
del mercado cualquiera que éste sea y
ese precio va a ser su curva de demanda
y su curva de ingreso marginal y hemos
hablado de que a largo plazo bajo una
competencia perfecta ninguna de estas
empresas podría obtener una ganancia
económica van a tener más participantes
lo que va a hacer bajar este precio y si
están obteniendo ganancias económicas
negativas entonces habrá gente que
saldrá y eso hará que esta línea se
mueva hacia arriba y así a largo plazo
estará en un punto donde ninguna de las
empresas estará obteniendo ganancias
económicas otra manera de pensar en esto
es donde nuestra curva de ingreso
marginal intersec a nuestra curva de
costo marginal que para cualquiera de
estas situaciones es la cantidad
racional que se debe producir la
cantidad racional que se debe producir
para una empresa que maximiza las
ganancias ese será exactamente el nivel
donde el precio es igual al costo total
promedio por lo que tiene cero ganancia
económica cero ganancia económica ahora
hay algunas cosas interesantes sobre
esto hablamos sobre cómo es la
asignación eficiente porque estamos
produciendo en una cantidad donde el
costo marginal es igual a la demanda
también es productivamente eficiente
porque estamos produciendo en el punto
mínimo de la curva de costo total
promedio por lo tanto es muy eficiente
desde un punto de vista productivo ahora
un monopolio es el extremo opuesto es el
único jugador en el mercado con barreras
a la entrada insuperables es el único
jugador por lo que podrías ver esto como
la curva de demanda del mercado pero es
su curva de demanda porque es el único
producto de modo que a precios altos
tienes una baja cantidad demandada y a
precios bajos tienes una gran cantidad
demandada en varios vídeos hemos hablado
de eso en muchas situaciones una empresa
monopólica no puede hacer discriminación
de precios tiene que cobrar el mismo
precio a cada consumidor bueno en esa
situación su ingreso marginal se
reducirá dos veces más rápido porque a
medida que avanza más y más en la curva
de demanda está bajando el precio para
todos y hemos estudiado esto todo esto
es un repaso nunca está de más tener un
repaso la cantidad racional para
producir y una vez
y esto es cierto para cualquier empresa
es donde el ingreso marginal intersec a
el costo marginal entonces produciríamos
esa cantidad y el precio de esa cantidad
iríamos a la curva de demanda sería
justo allí y podrías ver que esta
empresa monopólica puede obtener una
ganancia económica bastante buena porque
el costo total promedio en esa cantidad
está justo aquí y así desde una base por
unidad pueden hacer que la cantidad de
unidades sea muchas veces mayor y así
tienes una buena ganancia económica
ahora lo negativo desde un punto de
vista económico o de mercado si tuviera
la asignación eficiente estaría
produciendo en una cantidad donde el
costo marginal se intersecta con la
demanda pero eso no está sucediendo aquí
y de ese modo tienes toda esta pérdida
de eficiencia aquí ahora para ayudarte a
entender la competencia monopolística
digamos que comienzas como un monopolio
pero ahora de repente la dinámica del
mercado ha cambiado donde las barreras
de entrada insuperables ahora se
convierten en barreras de entrada
qué podría suceder bueno aquí tienes
esta buena ganancia económica por lo que
es probable que más empresas ingresen al
mercado y si más empresas ingresan al
mercado que pasará con tu curva de
demanda
bueno la demanda de tu producto
específico va a disminuir porque hay
otras personas que ofrecen alternativas
similares en la competencia
monopolística no existe una completa
homogeneidad en el producto que se vende
podrías tener una marca podrías tener
ciertas características que son mejores
o peores pero hay otros sustitutos que
la gente podría buscar que están
compitiendo contigo entonces a medida
que más y más personas ingresan a medida
que obtienes esa ganancia económica tu
curva de demanda particular se
desplazará hacia abajo y hacia la
izquierda y así tu curva de demanda
seguirá cambiando hasta que ya no puedas
obtener ninguna ganancia económica tu
curva de demanda podría ser algo así una
vez que las empresas no puedan obtener
ganancias económicas bueno entonces
realmente no tiene sentido que más
personas sienten
ingresar de modo que si comenzaste con
un monopolio tu demanda se movería hacia
la izquierda hasta el punto en que
obtengas esto y tu curva de ingreso
marginal se verá así tendrá el doble de
pendiente esta será tu curva de ingreso
marginal fíjate en lo que ha pasado
ahora ahora es racional que estés
produciendo en una cantidad en la que el
precio que estás obteniendo sea igual a
tu costo total promedio entonces una vez
más a medida que más y más personas
ingresaron porque estabas obteniendo
ganancias económicas y los participantes
en esta industria estaban obteniendo
ganancias económicas la curva de demanda
se ha desplazado a la izquierda por lo
que ahora hay ganancia económica cero a
largo plazo ahora una vez más esta es
una situación en la que tienes una
pérdida de eficiencia esto no es una
asignación eficiente no estás
produciendo a un nivel donde el costo
marginal es igual a la demanda tampoco
es productivamente eficiente para ser
productivamente eficiente deberías
producir en una cantidad que se
encuentren
punto mínimo de su curva de costo total
promedio y así esta diferencia de aquí
podríamos verla como la cantidad para la
escala eficiente esta distancia la
podrías ver como exceso de capacidad
exceso de capacidad ahora algo que
podría ser un poco contrario a la
intuición es que en vídeos anteriores
hablamos de cómo a medida que las
personas entran y salen de un mercado
cambiaría la curva de oferta pero aquí
estamos cambiando la curva de demanda
bueno cuando la gente entra y sale del
mercado cambia la curva de oferta para
todo el mercado no cambiará la curva de
demanda para todo el mercado pero lo que
hemos dibujado aquí no es la curva de
demanda para todo el mercado lo que
hemos dibujado aquí es la curva de
demanda para el producto de esta empresa
en particular entonces a medida que hay
más y más participantes en todo el
mercado la demanda de los productos de
esta empresa en particular está
disminuyendo